the ship needs to be all about
enchantment we take you into a world
where the design idea of Enchantment
will bring our shift and the stories
that we tell alive
we have over 1.2 million square feet of
spaces if you have chopped the ship up
and you laid it on the ground as
one-story pieces of venues and
staterooms and you name it it would
cover over 28 Acres our Disney wish will
be 144 000 gross tons so she's a really
big cruise ship there are boats that are
smaller than 39 meters in length right
but this is the width of the ship the
most impressive space on the Disney
wishes going through the grand hall
nowadays cruise ships don't typically
have very impressive Grand Halls anymore
it's actually really challenging from a
structural point of view
the grand hall is the heart and soul of
the ship it's of that intimate scale
that welcomes our guests very personally
onto the ship that's where we want you
to begin to forget everything else on
the outside world you're beginning this
magical cruise we have a lovely bronze
Cinderella she is holding Court over the
hall she's going to be welcoming us into
the cruise ship the right look for
Cinderella it was a matter of going back
to the original film and collecting many
stills of her my favorite close-up
of hers is this one here and it has the
the look on her face that I wanted to
have when the guests come into the ship
a Walt Disney theater is a large space
inside the ship not only does it have to
be free so there's no columns no pillars
in the middle because we want free
Sidelines for all our guests to watch
the show but then you have the added
element of the show itself the green on
the walls originally was going to be
another color interestingly enough
though we have a tremendous amount of
map projection in this space this color
takes projection really well map
projection has been a game changer for
us it really immerses guests in the
story we take over the entire space
through map projection right so it comes
out past the proscenium and just
envelops the whole theater it just
really helps tell the story I'm really
looking forward to this you know it's
been a couple of months since we've been
here whoa before it's built the 3D
renderings and the way that we walk from
space to space it truly was this
incredible guide we can see the finishes
the materials
we have over 126 unique carpets it might
sound easy like oh watch the carpet for
the 1243 State rooms be and that was
where publishing really helped us out it
was great when we met Laura she came
with her old design team she wanted us
to help her with the carpet design and I
pulled out a vintage Cinderella book and
there were these amazing borders that
were hand painted we just got really
inspired by the Vintage art and the
feelings we got from it Matt filigree
you can see how that has made its way
through so many things on the ship
the animation research Library houses
the vast collection of Animation artwork
from the company that stems back to the
early 20s we have about 65 million
pieces of Art in our collection
we have well over a thousand pieces of
artwork on this ship it's really
incredible for the 1923 restaurant we
had 14 display cases and so we found
some of the best pieces to help support
that storyline it's a museum in itself
there's no other place in the world
you'll see that amount of Disney artwork
true immersive design is guiding all of
your senses all of the emotions in your
guess in a way that's so touching it's
Unforgettable
[Music]